[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: We're so excited to
have Wendy here from Austin.
I think most of you know her.
She has fought tirelessly,
first as a Texas state senator,
and then in her
run for governor,
for women's reproductive
rights, gender
equal pay, LGBTQ rights, justice
for sexual assault survivors.
Just has an incredible
track record.
And I think you
probably also know her
for a somewhat historic
13-hour filibuster
in some pink sneakers.
[APPLAUSE]
And most recently,
she has started
an advocacy group called
Deeds Not Words, which we're
going to talk about today,
that is all about channeling
energy and passion
for gender equality
into actionable change.
So please welcome Wendy.
WENDY DAVIS: Hello, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Why don't we
start with Deeds Not Words?
Tell us a little bit about
it and why you founded it.
WENDY DAVIS: I started
Deeds Not Words--
it's a nonprofit organization--
about a year ago.
Really, starting
from the perspective
of wanting to make sure
that we were giving the best
opportunity for that next
generation of young women
who are going to be the
filibusterers of the future
to find their way to that path.
I travel and speak a lot.
And I was frequently
asked a question
that I'm still asked a lot,
which is, what do we do?
And you see this incredible
knowledge and passion,
but sometimes a
struggle about where
to connect that to action.
And so Deeds Not Words
was born, really,
with two big ideas in mind.
One is to make sure that
we're putting together,
in one place, an area
that you can go to,
a hub, our digital
hub, and you can
find a variety of different
organizations and the work
that they're doing in the
gender equality world.
And it's separated
by health, so things
that are happening in the
reproductive rights world,
for example.
Safety, which of course,
includes campus sexual assault,
human trafficking, and sexual
assault criminal justice reform
work.
Economic opportunity, which
includes a lot of organizations
that are working
on equality of pay,
on affordable quality
child care, on increasing
the minimum wage,
on family leave
policies, all of
those things that
make such an important
difference in our ability
to equalize our economic
opportunity in this country.
And then, leadership.
There are so many
different organizations.
You have one based right here
in California, Emerge, that
are really there for
women to make sure
that, where we have women who
are thinking about stepping
forward and running
for office, they
have the support around
them and the system that
helps them to raise
money and to have
the resources and the knowledge
that they need to do that
and to do it well.
So that's what we do
in the digital space.
We have a weekly
digital newsletter
called "The Deeds Digest."
And in that
newsletter, we inform.
We try to inspire.
I hope we do, sometimes.
And we end each "Deeds Digest"
with the do's of the week.
And those do's always
tie in to the things
that we talked about in
that particular newsletter.
And then we do a "Daily Deed."
We started doing that just a few
weeks ago, post-women's march,
trying to make sure that, where
people were looking for a way
to plug in and some direction
and guidance in that regard,
we do that.
That's all the digital
part of what we do.
The other piece of
it-- and certainly,
this is how I found my way
into the political world--
is helping us to find
our power as advocates.
It can be kind of hard to
navigate your way into that
and to know exactly
how to do it.
I think that Indivisible has
been such an important resource
in helping people to see how we
can use our voices in a very,
very powerful way.
And I love the structure
and the guidance
that they've put
together for that.
We are doing tactical
trainings of advocacy work.
So we started in Texas.
We have our eye on
several other states
that we want to
expand into, but we're
working with both high school
and college-aged young women.
And we're helping to
foster their voices
into the legislative process.
So they're working
on two key issues
right now with a
number of legislators,
from idea to how you write
a piece of legislation,
to coming to committee
hearings and testifying for it.
And how you present
yourself and how
to make a most
effective argument.
And the areas that we're
really focusing on in that work
are sex trafficking of minors.
And also, sexual assault reforms
in both the criminal justice
world, rape kit backlog, for
example, statute of limitations
issues, but also
campus sexual assault.
And changing the landscape
of what our understanding is
about consent, how we define
that, how we define yes,
rather than no means no.
What does it mean to say yes?
So we're focused
on those things.
And we find that
our young audience
is very interested
and passionate
about those particular issues.
And so it's been
a really good way
to foster their advocacy skills.
SPEAKER 1: What's been the most
surprising thing that you've
discovered since starting?
WENDY DAVIS: I guess just the
challenge of taking an idea.
I can do the political
thing pretty well.
I know how to navigate
my way in that world.
And that's a learning curve,
too, just like anything.
But it's a learning
curve for me right now,
how to take these ideas and
most effectively implement them.
And just how hard it
is to be a startup.
A startup nonprofit is
no different, really,
than a startup profit
other than you,
obviously, don't
need to make money.
You need people to
donate money to you.
SPEAKER 1: The VCs are
maybe a little less excited
about the nonprofit
startup, right?
WENDY DAVIS: I guess
that's so true.
Yeah.
But I think most surprising
is just how eager people are
to be connected
in ways that make
them feel like their voices
really make a difference.
And they do make a difference.
They truly do.
SPEAKER 1: It sounds
like, from everything
you're talking
about, that to you,
the biggest way to
effect political--
to change the current political
landscape would be to get
more women out there, involved?
WENDY DAVIS: No question.
SPEAKER 1: What else?
Obviously, you need to have
your focus on, say, advocacy.
What other areas do
you think could be
making a difference right now?
I'm sure there are a lot
of people in this room
and on the livestream
that want to know how
they could get more involved.
What do you think is
the most effective?
WENDY DAVIS: You and I had a
great conversation a moment ago
before we came up here.
And I thought you actually
characterized and crystallized
this perfectly.
What you were saying was that we
have to pick those two or three
things that we are really going
to care about and dive into.
And try to avoid the
temptation, because there's
so much going on right now, to
weigh in on every little space.
So whatever that area
of passion is for you,
whether it's the environment, or
LGBTQ equality, or transgender
rights, in specific,
or women's equality,
and all of the different
realms of that,
find the place that
really connects to you
or that you connect to.
Because what you'll find--
I've certainly always
found this in my life--
if you follow the thing
that you really care about
and you use your
energy on that thing,
it's going to take
you to a place
that you wouldn't have expected.
And it's going to be
unbelievably fulfilling.
Both personally, but
also with your ability
to actually have an
impact on it because it's
coming from a place
that's really true to you.
So whatever that is,
look for organizations
that are working in that world.
If it's voting rights, ACLU.
If it's women's
reproductive freedoms,
obviously, you know the
incredible organizational work
of groups like Planned
Parenthood and NARAL.
But maybe you don't know
so much about the Center
for Reproductive
Rights, which is doing
all the legal work on this.
And actually, were
the major impetus
behind the successful
Supreme Court case
that we won last year.
Maybe you care particularly
about making sure
that women have access to
safe and legal abortion.
And you want to really get
into the ground level of that
and support organizations
like the Lilith Fund, which
makes sure that women can afford
to have an abortion if they
otherwise don't have the
financial means to do that.
So there are so many
different ways to plug in.
And what we hope to
do with our website--
and we're actually in a revamp
of it right now to make it much
more meaningful if you're
looking for that place to plug
in--
we want to be a place
where you can go,
and depending on that
area of interest,
you plug in to one of
those organizations
and you will find, immediately,
two or three key ways
that they're asking
for you to get
involved on a real-time basis.
Some more intense and
some less intense,
but ways where you can
meaningfully be contributing
your time and your energy.
SPEAKER 1: And what
about companies?
What role do you think companies
should or shouldn't have?
Have you seen their
advocacy be effective?
WENDY DAVIS: I
think their advocacy
is tremendously effective.
I'm sensitive,
obviously, to the fact
that companies walk quite
a fine line, in terms
of not wanting to get involved
so much in the partisan world.
And that makes sense because
they have consumers who
sit on both sides of that line.
They have, I'm
sure, employees that
sit on both sides of that line.
But I think we find our way
into the things that make sense
when we are being
very issue-focused.
For example, last year in
my home state of Texas,
American Airlines
became the title sponsor
of the Planned
Parenthood luncheon
in Dallas for the
very first time.
I almost cried.
I was so blown away by it.
Because it made such a powerful
statement for a company
like that to say, we support
women's reproductive health
care and this organization.
And in the face of
all the political flak
that Planned Parenthood
is in the midst of,
we're going to step forward
and we're going to do this.
So I think, for companies
to find their way into issue
areas that really
matter to them,
and to use their influence--
and there are many ways for
them to do that, of course.
We certainly saw the incredible
impact in North Carolina
last year with the
transgender bathroom bill.
Texas, by the way, is trying
to replicate that right now.
And I am pleased to see we've
got some corporate pushback
already beginning to percolate.
But that corporate
pushback in North Carolina
not only contributed to,
really, an economic impact
to the state, but it made such a
powerful statement economically
that it impacted the way voters
thought about that issue.
So that in the last
gubernatorial race
that they had during the
presidential election cycle,
they elected a
statewide Democrat.
That was considered a
really long-shot thing
to do there, actually.
And they did it because people
now were coming at this issue
from a variety of perspectives.
Whether it was something
that they cared about
from their social conscience
or whether they cared about it
because they understood
it was having
an impact economically
to their state
and maybe to their
own pocketbook.
That's what companies
have the power to do.
And to broaden the conversation
in a way that really
does lift it up out of the
social and makes it something
that's much more meaningful in
the day-to-day lives of people
who have respect for
or who are impacted
by the decisions and the
actions that that company takes.
SPEAKER 1: So where do you
think companies are still
being silent?
On what issue do you wish
companies were speaking out
more about?
WENDY DAVIS: Well,
when I looked at what
happened in North Carolina,
with appreciation and awe
for the companies that stepped
forward so powerfully on that
and objected to
it, I found myself
longing for that same
response in other areas.
I, of course, am very
focused on gender equality.
And I wish we saw more of
that when it came to issues
that particularly impact women.
In Texas, when we passed that
anti-abortion bill in 2013,
that was, in and of
itself, terrible.
But what happened, actually,
two years prior to that
that a lot of people
didn't know about--
there was no big filibuster.
It didn't capture the attention
of people around the world.
In 2011, in an assault
on Planned Parenthood,
there was a dramatic defunding
of women's health care there.
And they couldn't
really de-select just
Planned Parenthood.
And so what happened
was that there
was this wholesale
withdrawal of funds.
Number one, the state decided
to no longer participate
in the women's
health program, which
was giving us about
$30 million a year
for women's reproductive
health care.
It's aimed particularly at
lowering the Medicaid birthrate
and saving taxpayer money
by virtue of doing it.
And it really was saving
a tremendous amount
of taxpayer money.
We de-participated in that.
And that affected not
just Planned Parenthood,
but everyone that
was getting money
for birth control,
reproductive health care
services in our state.
And then there was
also a $78 million
state defunding of these
women's reproductive health care
centers.
None of these were
providing abortion care, not
a single one.
And overnight, we had
over 80 clinics close all
over our state.
Those that still remained
open were hobbled really badly
and could only see a small
percentage of the patients
that they'd been seeing.
And there's a wide
range of estimates
about the number of
women who were impacted,
but it's anywhere from 100,000
to 180,000 women in one
fell swoop.
And we see the circumstances
of that in our state.
We have the highest
maternal death
rate of any developed
country in the world
in the state of Texas.
Our maternal death rate doubled
in about a six-year period
of time.
So these are dramatic,
horrific human consequences
that women are getting
sucked into by virtue
of partisan politics.
And I want to see companies
step forward and say,
when these sorts of things
are happening, you know what?
We were going to relocate
our corporate headquarters
to Dallas, Texas, and
now we've decided not to.
Or we're the NCAA,
and we were going
to host the Final Four there
and now we've decided not to.
Or we're the Super Bowl
and we were coming,
but now we're not going to.
I want to see that
kind of response
when women are under
assault. Because it's not
just that we are
failing to realize
our full equal opportunity.
It's that we literally
are the shrapnel
in these political wars where
human lives are being impacted
in devastating ways.
And it's something that we
all ought to care about.
Because at the end of the
day, it impacts everyone.
And at the end of the day, it
impacts our economy as well.
SPEAKER 1: So how do you do it?
This, obviously,
disproportionately,
dramatically affects
the poor, right?
WENDY DAVIS: It does.
SPEAKER 1: And then you
have wealthier women
who are at these companies.
How do you get them to
stand up in the same way
that people have stood up
for rights for other groups
that they don't
necessarily belong to?
WENDY DAVIS: I think
part of it starts
within the culture of the
organization, the company
itself.
And what is the
makeup of that company
look like, in terms of the
number of women on its board,
the number of women that
are in the executive suites
of that company?
That has a lot of influence
in these conversations.
And so continuing
for gender equality
in the positions
that women occupy
is a very important
part of that,
just as is the case for making
sure that we have women fully
reflected at every level of
representative government
in this country.
Unless and until
we have that, we're
not going to move this
conversation, really,
where it needs to go.
But we have an opportunity,
as employees and as consumers,
too, to exert our
own influences.
We've been talking about that
a bit at Deeds Not Words.
When I first was
hatching this idea,
one of the things I wanted us
ultimately to be able to do
is to weigh in as consumers
and to help direct consumer
decision-making
based on a company's
score with how well it's doing
to support gender equality.
Is this a company where there
are a representative number
of women in the executive
suites and on the board?
Is this a company
that's, like Salesforce,
done a self-examination
of pay equity
and worked hard to make sure
they were equalizing it?
Is it a company that has a
good family leave policy, both
for dads and moms,
so that we do have
true gender equality in the
way that that's happening?
And helping to drive
people's positive
buying decisions
based on companies
that score well in that regard.
Right now, I'm sure you've
all seen Grab Your Wallet.
And Grab Your Wallet
is doing, I think,
an interesting
job of making sure
that they're making
people aware of how
to take their dollars away,
as consumers, from companies
who aren't behaving well.
I have found myself
responding to that
and thinking about which ride
share company I'm going to use,
for example, or which
retail establishment--
not Macy's-- that
I'm going to shop at.
I have my own
experience with Macy's.
Because they actually
advocated against an equal pay
law in Texas and were successful
in getting the governor
to veto an equal pay law that
I worked very, very hard on.
So if any of you are
shopping at Macy's, I'm
just going to add my two cents
to what's already on the Grab
Your Wallet site when it comes
to that particular company.
But we have influences
in that regard.
And I think we're starting
to see some of the response
that private companies are
making to watching the way
consumers are responding.
This young woman that we were
talking about earlier, who just
recently left Uber and who
shared her story, essentially,
for the outside world.
And the immediate
impact that that's had.
While she worked within that
culture for a very long time,
trying to change it, bringing
outside attention on it
and having the
executive offices have
to deal with the public
opinion of their company
based on that experience, it
has shown we have a lot of power
if we can really
kind of focus that--
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I think it will be--
WENDY DAVIS: --magnifying glass.
SPEAKER 1: --interesting
to see as that gets easier.
Right now, it's very almost--
it's an entirely,
almost, offline
or an individual
experience where
you can post on social that
you've boycotted something
or supported something.
But it'll be interesting
to see how that evolves
as, I think, the tech solutions
get easier for, like you said,
the companies that are
doing the things that
align with your values and
how that gets surfaced.
So how did you
get into politics?
And what was the moment where
you were just like, oh, wow,
I'm a big deal?
WENDY DAVIS: I promise you,
I haven't had that moment.
SPEAKER 1: It
wasn't when you had
a catheter during a filibuster?
WENDY DAVIS: I know
we all do this,
but I think women
particularly do this.
We take in all the things
that we're not achieving,
as opposed to celebrating the
things that we're doing well.
We tend to be very
self-critical.
But my entree into
politics, and the reason
that I was really committed
to the advocacy training
work of Deeds Not
Words, happened when I
went to a city council meeting.
I was in my 30s.
I was arguing for something
in my neighborhood,
along with a lot of other people
in the neighborhood community.
And I walked into that council
chamber, expressed my opinion,
and then just got
the idea, well, I
could be one of those
people sitting up there.
And this is
interesting, actually.
And I think I would really
thrive in this environment.
And so it just opened
up the idea for me.
I had not been paying
attention to politics.
I was one of those people that
I really work on right now.
I was a young single mom.
I was working two jobs
and going to school.
And my struggles did
not include the thought
about how my voice
could make a difference
in the political world.
And I really didn't sit
up and pay attention to it
until I saw Hillary Clinton
fighting for universal health
care as First Lady.
That was my first
tug into it, where
it seemed relevant and
meaningful to me, based
on my own experiences and
struggles with health care
as an uninsured person.
So we find our ways,
again, I think,
when we're helped to
demystify that process where
we see that those fancy
capitol buildings,
whether we're talking
about the one in DC
or the ones around our states,
those buildings belong to us.
There's nothing really
mysterious or intimidating
about them.
And I think we have
to demystify them.
And I'm pleased to be doing
that for some young people
in my own state and helping
them to see that the people that
are elected there,
while they may refer
to it as my district or
my office, the district
is actually one that
belongs to the people.
Their office belongs to us.
They have to, at
least at some level,
listen to us, even if they
do avoid us in town halls,
which some of them around
the country have been doing.
But we have the power to speak
out by calling their offices,
writing their offices,
coming to committee hearings,
and letting them know
how we feel about things.
And I hope that
the more people we
can encourage into that
venue, the more young women
will see that they
have every right
to be sitting up at those
decision-making tables.
And that they'll begin to view
that as something that they
want to do for themselves.
SPEAKER 1: And
yet, I imagine one
of the most discouraging
things when you're
thinking about running for any
kind of office or speaking up
is that you always
know that this is all
going to be seen through
the lens of your gender.
I remember when you were running
for governor and there was--
how many hours a week did
you spend with your kids?
Right?
Or it was like, how
many days in a month
did you go back
to see your kids?
Which never, ever,
ever would happen.
And that's got to be something
that's quite discouraging,
not only just the public
aspect of this all,
but knowing that you're
going to be-- you
have to fight twice as
hard to be taken seriously.
How did you navigate that?
You know, to a certain degree,
you have to play that game,
that you can't
transcend it entirely.
At the same time,
you want to have
control over your narrative.
How did you approach that?
Or how do you approach
it today, too?
WENDY DAVIS: For
me, it's still one
of the most
frustrating experiences
that I've had in
the political world.
And women face this in
every level of profession.
One of the things that was
successfully done to me during
my gubernatorial race--
and it was really--
if I stand aside and just
look at it as a spectator,
I'm rather fascinated by it.
Being in the middle of it,
it was horrific and painful.
But one of the
clever things that
happens in the
political world is
trying to figure out how to
take a candidate's best asset
and make it their weakness.
And that's what
happened with me.
My asset was my story.
The American dream story
of coming from poverty,
struggling, fighting,
making my way,
all the way through
Harvard Law School.
First person in my family
to ever even go to college,
never mind graduate.
And then to have a
career where I gave back
to my own life experiences and
the things that I fought for.
That was my feather, right?
That was the thing that I
could distinguish myself about.
Well, my story got
ripped out from under me.
I was a bad mother.
I commuted back and
forth from Boston
to Fort Worth in my second
and third year of law school
because that first year,
taking my girls there
with me was not just really hard
on me, it was so hard on them.
And where a man would never
have been questioned about that,
my bona fides as a mother
was called into question.
My two daughters actually
had to come forward.
And they wrote a
very heartfelt letter
that they read publicly about
my bona fides as a mother.
You just wouldn't see
this happening for men.
But I understood why
they were doing it.
And I also understood
with some of the labels
that they used with me,
why they were doing them.
Abortion Barbie was a label that
was used quite often for me.
And in fact, when I came to do
some fund raising in Southern
California during
that race, there
were these big posters that
had been put up all over LA
with-- they were 3D
posters with Barbie,
plastic, transparent
belly with a plastic baby
doll in the belly, and me
with scissors in my hand.
So why would they do that?
Well, a couple of things.
Number one, they wanted to
make me a candidate that
was all about abortion
and to take away
the entire body of work that
I had done as a public servant
and what I had to
offer as a candidate.
But they also wanted--
the Barbie image
was very purposeful.
If we can invite voters to think
about women candidates in terms
of how we look, then we dismiss
our capacity as leaders.
We're inviting people to
think about them as mothers,
and bad mothers at that.
As women who are no more
than the makeup of what
we look like.
And to, therefore, take
away our perspectives
about our true value as leaders.
It happens to women in the
political world all the time.
I am not unique.
It was particularly
bad in my race.
And it was particularly
bad in Hillary's race,
but it happens to
women all the time.
And I think the best
way to ride through that
and to rise above
it is to continue
to fight back every single
time and to pop right back up.
That was one of the things that
I always admired about Hillary.
I have never seen anyone
that could pop right back up
and get back out there
and fight another day.
And it's unfortunate
that we have to do it,
but it's the reality.
And I think unless
and until we have
more women in those
gubernatorial mansions,
unless and until we have
a woman in the White House
and we can show the
incredible capacity
that women have to lead in
those executive positions,
we're going to
continue to struggle
with these stereotypes.
So I'm really
committed to just doing
everything we can
to chip away at it
in school boards,
in city councils,
in every state legislative
body in this country.
And obviously, at the
congressional and, of course,
the presidential level, too.
SPEAKER 1: And so
you lost the race.
And in the Valley, we love
to talk about failure.
How it makes us all stronger
and there's usually a story of,
oh, I failed at this.
And then, I was bankrupt.
And I looked up at
the stars and realized
I would disrupt the auto
industry or something.
And then you become
this billionaire.
Did you have an
equivalent moment?
Did you take anything
from that failure?
WENDY DAVIS: Most definitely.
I wrote an essay for Lena
Dunham's "Lenny Letter"
within a few months
of that race.
And if it's OK for me
to say a curse word,
the title of my essay was
"I Fucking Hate To Lose."
And I talked about what
a competitive person
I am by nature.
I'm sure a lot of
you are, as well.
But going back to that
beautiful Teddy Roosevelt
quote about what it
means to be in the ring.
To be that person who sweats
and tries their hardest
and comes up short.
But how much more glorious
it is to be that person than
to be the person who is standing
on the sideline as the critic.
It's only when we put
ourselves out there
and we risk losing that we
will ever move the ball.
There's value no matter what
in that moving of the ball.
I know, in the political world,
that in places like Texas,
a lot of times
these conversations,
these hard conversations that
need to be had about policy,
they're not being
had except for when
we have these big,
statewide contests where
we can raise the conversation
and the level of consciousness
around them.
And for me, that was a
really important part
of running for office.
But the same can
be said of anything
that we are working to do.
Anything we're striving
for that's hard
and that we may fail at.
Every attempt we
make at it advances
it a little bit
and we, ultimately,
will succeed in those goals.
Whether it's me
individually or not,
I will have played a part
in moving that ball forward.
And so in my essay, what I said
was, if you're going to fail,
fail big.
Fail gloriously
trying to do something
that really matters to you.
And when you fail and you
deal with that consequence,
in terms of how that
feels, really try to center
yourself around
how extraordinary
you are that you tried it
and that you moved the ball.
And then, if you've got it
in you-- and I hope you do--
get back up and
try to do it again.
SPEAKER 1: I've
got more questions,
but I bet there's
probably some Dory.
Are we doing live, as well?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you
come combat and deal
with people who have violently
opposed views to you, even
on base principles, and then
get to talking policy with them
afterwards if their base
beliefs are different?
WENDY DAVIS: There are some
people that you can't talk to.
I know that's not a very
constructive answer.
In my legislative experience,
for example, I really
prided myself on
working across the aisle
and got quite a lot of
legislation passed doing that.
You have to do that in Texas.
It's a quite predominantly
Republican place.
But there are some areas where
it's worth drawing that line,
where you can't find
a way to compromise.
And I think the
most effective way
to communicate when you're
in that place, or any
of these places actually, even
where you do find that middle,
is to do it through personal
experiences and human stories.
A lot of times, we have
these conversations
up in the ethereal
world and we're
stuck in our own ideological
way of thinking about them.
But when we can
make them more real,
it really makes a difference.
So a great example of how
that can move the ball.
In the conversation
around LGBTQ equality,
that really began to move
when a great deal of work
was done determining
how to talk about it.
And to talk about
it in a way that
was more resonant than
had been the case.
It had been talked about
specifically as equality.
And that we all ought
to care about it just
to be living in a
full and equal world
and that we all ought
to be treated that way.
But the conversation
shifted, purposefully so,
to be much more personal.
And a lot of work actually was
done in your state around that.
Door-to-door
conversations with people
were had where couples
who were impacted
by the inequality of marriage
equality, for example,
would go to an older
Republican household and say,
we want to talk to you about
why this matters to us.
It really shifted people's
thinking about it.
And it's because
it became personal
and because they saw it
as something personal.
Storytelling is powerful.
And I love seeing the
fact that it's becoming
more and more prominent.
That technology has provided
such a great platform
for people to share stories
and to influence based on that.
A lot of abortion story-sharing
going on online post-2013
in the filibuster and
people's consciousness
raising about that.
And I think that's
our most effective way
to try to get through
hard conversations.
But that doesn't mean everyone's
always going to listen.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm
Monica, and I'm
so excited that you're here.
I grew up in South Texas.
And when I was growing up,
Ann Richards was the governor.
So I'm going to ask a question
on the topic of failure again.
She was the first governor
I got to vote for.
I went on to work in President
Clinton's first White House.
Barbara Boxer, Dianne Feinstein,
all these women were running.
And I felt so invigorated
as a young woman coming out
of college.
It's a very different story now.
And I look at that from when I
was young and where we are now.
Everything that Hillary
Clinton's had to go through.
Everything that Elizabeth Warren
is going through, et cetera.
Everything you've gone through.
And thank you, by the way,
for going through that.
Where have we failed?
And what do I tell my daughter?
WENDY DAVIS: It's
such a hard question.
The "what do I
tell my daughter?"
is such a hard question.
The night of the election--
I have a 34-year-old and
a 28-year-old daughter.
And I was at the
event in Manhattan.
I had phone conversations
with both of my daughters
that evening, both of them
crying their eyes out.
And both of them
asking questions
from a place of
what was real fear.
What's going to happen?
I feel really
optimistic right now
about the what's going
to happen because I
am so encouraged by
the personal reaction
that people have had to saying,
we're going to step forward
and we're going
to use our voices.
What you tell your
daughter, I hope,
is to participate in that
with you to the extent
that you participate in it.
Show her, through role modeling,
the power that you have
and how you're
going to express it.
And show her that you're
going to sustain it.
I think that's one of the
big questions right now.
Are we going to
sustain this enthusiasm
that we have right now for
our values and our desire
to make sure that they're
going to be heard?
But at that top
level, once again,
I think it is our very
important responsibility
to make sure that
we're doing everything
we can to create legislative
bodies that reflect
who we are as a community.
And that doesn't just mean
making sure we have women.
It means making sure we
have women of color who
are dramatically
under-represented
in legislative bodies
around this country.
That we have transgender
representatives.
That we have people
from different cultures,
and religions, and
backgrounds, both
socioeconomically and otherwise.
Unless we're really reflected
in the decision-makers,
we're not going to move things
forward as productively and as
effectively and as quickly
as we'd like to see.
So if you're going to spend
your energy somewhere,
I would say run for office.
Or find a candidate
that you can get behind
and that you can help.
Not just by writing them
a $5 check every week,
but making sure that you go
knock on some doors for them
and you have some conversations
about why their election makes
a difference.
Republicans, for
a long time, have
been very astute at
building from the base up
and making sure that
they are putting people
in places where they have
the potential to climb
in the political world.
So the school board races
and city council races,
which is where I started, too.
It's a really important way
for us to make an impact.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's Mina.
And first, I just want
to say thanks for coming.
And also, thank you because you
really personally affected me.
I actually did knock
on doors for you
in Texas as part of
Battleground Texas.
And I really want to say that
I feel like you revitalized
politics in Texas.
Everyone that I
spoke to, we spoke
to a number of people
who actually said,
we're switching parties.
They were frustrated
and I felt like you
had a big part in that.
WENDY DAVIS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And as
you mentioned, we
are seeing a revitalization in
interest in politics and people
getting involved.
My question is,
you also see women
voting against their own
interests a lot of the time.
And I feel like it is because
they just focus on one issue.
How can we make it a
larger conversation
so that they actually,
perhaps, want
to start supporting each
other rather than tearing
each other down?
WENDY DAVIS: I like the way
you ended that last question
because it made me think
of something that Chelsea
Handler said recently about
women, that we've been taught
to tackle, not to climb.
And I do think sometimes we
can be each other's own worst
enemy because there's a lot
of judgment that goes on.
Depending on the choices that
we've made in our own lives
and careers, or whether that
career is outside the home
or inside the home.
This is the $20 million
question, though.
How do we make sure that
people aren't voting
against their own interests?
And there's a lot
of education that
needs to take place
because people aren't going
to vote against
their own interests
because they think they're
voting against their interests.
They really believe they're
voting in their interests,
right?
And I think Democrats
have failed,
myself included,
in doing a good job
of communicating why it is that
our values are ones that really
are more in alignment with
most people's in this country.
And there's a lot of work
being done right now on,
how do we reframe the narrative?
And how do we do a better
job of talking about that?
But back to that
personal storytelling
again, where we have
experiences that we
can share with people
who may disagree with us
and paint a picture of a
real person and an impact
that would feel more
compelling to them.
Where you have
opportunities to do that,
I think that's the most powerful
way to cut through that.
And particularly,
if there's a way
to paint within their
own perspective what's
happening to them
vis-a-vis a person
that they may have
thought was actually
aligned with their interests.
AUDIENCE: First of all, I
agree with the optimism.
And I think that's
just because everyone's
having such a big wake-up call.
So when I came to this country
four years ago from London,
I was maybe a latent feminist.
I've always believed
in equality, et cetera,
but it wasn't an issue for me.
And then I came to the Valley,
where everyone was male
and everyone was working in
tech and everyone was white.
These issues became more
important for me, personally.
But now, it's because
it's so bad with Trump,
it feels like the
entire middle ground
of people who just
didn't care anymore
and didn't seem to be
caring about politics
have been awakened.
So I actually think this might
turn out to be a good thing.
I'm sharing the optimism.
But I wanted to ask
you about this question
about personal storytelling,
which I totally understand,
in terms of building tolerance.
If you're relating to this
person, it's different.
And it reminds me when I was
16, I was in upstate New York
as an exchange student in
a family that was un-eco,
blatantly racist,
all these things.
And so my dad would shout at
black people out of this pickup
truck--
my host dad.
But then, Bob, who
was the black guy who
worked with him,
somehow wasn't black
because he was Bob,
because he knew him.
So I think that's what
you're getting at, right?
Once you know the
person, you can no longer
put them into this
category of otherness.
But on the flip side,
with the politicians,
it seems like we're moving
further and further away
from issues and more and more
about the personality, in that
Trump got elected because
of his personality that
appeals to TV viewers.
And it was nothing
about the issues, right?
Everyone ignored all the issues.
So how can we
square those things?
Should we get politics
away from personalities
and more towards issues again,
or is that just impossible?
WENDY DAVIS: I don't
know if that's possible.
But I think a lot
of people, too,
would tell you
that they supported
Donald Trump because
they did believe
that he was
supportive of policies
that were going to have a
positive impact on their lives.
So whether we were
talking about people
who had been impacted
by automation,
but he gave an easy
target to blame,
which was an immigrant workforce
that had taken your job.
Whether we're
talking about people
who worked in industries
where environmental evolution
and the protections
of environmental laws
had decreased the
employment capacity
in that particular sector and
they'd been impacted by that,
they heard him speaking
to them about that.
Never underestimate the
misogyny that is out there
and even if it's not something
that people bring forward
consciously, their
own subconscious
feelings about the threat
that equality in the workforce
means to their own
livelihoods and success,
he spoke powerfully to
a lot of those things
and people were
responding to them.
But I love your example
about Bob, right?
Because that's the only way
that we can really counter that.
There was a great story
in "The New York Times"
yesterday about a
Mexican gentleman
who was detained recently
and he's probably
going to be deported.
And in this small Iowa
town, he was so well loved.
And everyone's
saying, well, yeah, we
support rounding up and
deporting, but not him.
I think his name is Carlos.
We love Carlos.
And Carlos had done all
these incredible things
in the community, like
supporting firefighters
and always being the person
there with the food drives
and different things like that.
And everyone loves them.
So making the reality
come to life for people
is really a way to
take a step back
and to look at
things differently.
The real challenge
that we have is not
that there are
personalities in politics
that can be persuasive, but that
we have a media culture where
people self-select the
prism through which they
view their news.
And they're going to hear
things and be told things
very differently depending
on that self-selection.
That, to me, is the greatest
challenge that we have,
is cutting through
the version of things
that you find on
different news sources.
And the decisions
or the opinions
that you form based on what you
hear coming from those filters.
And we all owe a
responsibility, again,
to take the power away
from their version
and put the power into
a reality version that's
based on real human impact.
It's hard, but we're each
an influencer and we each
have an opportunity to do it
to our spheres of influence.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Monique.
I'm an immigrant, a
woman, and a Latina.
So I 100% relate to
your daughter's fears
about what's going on.
And on top of that,
like many others,
I have the opposite
concern from hers.
I'm raising a white male
in the Silicon Valley
and I'm deeply
concerned about what
he's going to grow up listening
to at school and on the TV,
and so on.
It was very
frustrating not being
able to vote last election.
So I guess my question
to you would be,
how do you think
we that do not get
to vote in this country
can have the biggest
impact beyond the ballots?
WENDY DAVIS: In myriad of ways.
And again, find the thing
that feels most authentic
and of value to you personally.
If it's in the political space,
obviously supporting candidates
and working for them, even
if you can't vote for them.
For example in Texas, I had
a large number of Dreamers
who worked really, really
hard on our campaign.
None of whom could actually
vote for me, but all of whom
had a vested stake in what
the outcome of that election
looked like, and who cared
very deeply about the direction
that we were going as a state.
You have a wonderful
opportunity with your son
to be an influencer
in the way he
is going to view these issues.
And I'm sure he's going
to grow up beautifully
based on who you are and what
your values are and making sure
that you pass those on to him.
If you find yourself
really deeply
passionate about LGBT equality,
or the environment, or gender
equality, find an organization
that matters to you
and support the
work that they do.
And ask them how you can
be valuable to the work
that they do.
There's so much that's
needed, in terms
of our time and our
passion that, as long
as you find a place that
feels meaningful to you,
you will be making a difference.
You really will, whether you
can ultimately vote or not.
SPEAKER 2: And Wendy, we're
going to take one more
question from a man
who's been watching
over the livestream who asked,
"How do you see the role of men
as allies?
What can we do to
help this cause?"
WENDY DAVIS: That's a
really good question.
First of all, I'll tell
you a story about myself
and the word "feminism," back
to what was said earlier.
When I was in my 30s
and I was running
for city council for the first
time, I was asked by a reporter
whether I was a feminist.
And I answered the question no.
And I'm ashamed to tell
you that, honestly.
But I want to tell
you because I want
us to do some self-exploration
about our own attitudes
and perspectives.
Why did I do that?
Well, I felt like it
was categorizing me
in this limited way and
defining me in a way
that other people would
look at and disqualify me
based on that categorization.
But by doing that, I was playing
a role in marginalizing women.
What I would love
to see more of--
and I'm so pleased to see
so much of it right now--
are men stepping forward and
saying, I'm a feminist, too.
Because to be a
feminist, really it just
means that you support the
idea that we should all
be equal in society
and the economy.
What's that bumper sticker?
Feminism is the radical notion
that women are human beings,
or something like that.
I'm really encouraged
about that, too, though,
and where we are.
The marches, the women's
marches that took place
around the country
and around the world,
there were so many men.
There were so many
beautiful, wonderful men
stepping forward and saying,
this matters to all of us.
AUDIENCE: I'm with her.
WENDY DAVIS: I'm
with her, exactly.
And I think more men
are looking at this
from the prism of their
mothers and their sisters
and, especially,
their daughters,
and wanting to create a world
where they have the opportunity
to fulfill their
dreams and their best
opportunities for themselves.
And so more and more, we're
joining this conversation
as one.
And I think one of
the powerful ways
that we can talk about it is
the fact that when we are all
working toward gender equality,
we're actually all working
to a place where our
economy has the strongest
opportunity to thrive.
And it really goes
back to looking
at what happened when women
were able to really enter
the workforce and stay in
the full-time workforce
for the first time.
It was in the 1970s.
And I know a lot of the really
young people in this room
cannot even fathom.
But as of 1971, birth
control was illegal.
If you were not married, you
could not have birth control.
In 1972, with a
Supreme Court decision
that's much less known than Roe
v. Wade, Eisenstadt v. Baird,
birth control became legal
for unmarried persons, not
just married persons.
There had been a Supreme Court
decision a few years prior
to that that allowed married
people to access birth control.
So birth control and then,
of course, Roe v. Wade.
With our right to
make determinations
about our own bodies,
we could suddenly
decide that we were going
to enter the workforce
and we were going to stay
there if we wanted to.
And the women's participation
rate in the workforce
took this huge climb.
It went from about
the low-20 percentile
to the mid-40 percentile over
the course of the next three
decades and hung there.
And because it hung there,
we contributed significantly
to the economic output the
economic growth of the country.
About an estimated $1.7 trillion
in 2012, which pays for,
by the way, Medicaid, Medicare,
and Social Security combined.
Just our participation, our
increased participation,
from the 1970s to that point
is responsible for being
able to pay for all
of those programs.
So we all have a vested stake
in women's equality and women
being able to realize our
full economic participation
in this country.
And I want to hear more
women and men sharing that
with their friends
and their coworkers.
That this isn't
just a social issue.
It's not just about saying,
we ought to treat everyone
fairly and equally.
We all have an
economic stake in it.
And it goes back to that saying
that a lot of people think
is just a trite,
little campaign saying.
When women do better,
we all do better.
It's really true.
And so we all have not
only a stake in it,
but we ought to be
exercising our voices
and making sure that
we're spreading greater
understanding about that.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Well, thank you so
much for coming.
WENDY DAVIS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]